one of the most attractive features of
another person is their authenticity
we're highly wired highly tuned to
detect someone's authenticity why
because to be lied to to be tricked
during evolution was a really bad idea
and also the authenticity of a company
it's not enough just to have a purpose
you know you can have these wonderful
purposes but unless you're authentic in
it it's just a slogan and people will
detect that in
authenticity welcome to the show
thank you very much chris good to be
here we were just talking about what
happens if you can hear your own voice
briefly after you say it so it's like
your mum's old phone on loudspeaker and
you're speaking and then her
microphone catches the audio out of the
speaker and sends it back to you what
happens with your brain what are you
talking about there
uh well if you're
if you actually hear your voice a
fraction of a second after you've spoken
your your brain doesn't know what to do
and eventually if it keeps happening
you'll just stop talking you're
literally your brain just says shut up
you just stopped talking and not just
because of the content i mean part of it
what you're actually saying
so you actually bore yourself but it's
more than that it's actually the um it
just can't cope with that because of
course we are used to hearing our voice
immediately
so now if i hear it almost like an echo
uh your brain can't deal with it
so it just just stops
just gets worse and worse sounds to me
like the audio version
of when you see a face that's got two
sets of eyes on it
have you seen this where they stack two
eyes over each other and you're when you
look at it there's a skull on a wall on
my drive to the gym in newcastle and
there's a skull with two sets of eyes
two eye holes perfectly done and even
looking at that my brain just isn't
quite happy
it knows there's something
amiss you know that there's something
wrong yeah yeah
absolutely i mean we're
people don't realize of course how
strongly and we'll get into this i'm
sure how strongly we're wired to see
what's familiar
uh and how in that sense we're actually
wired to detect the unfamiliar
because your brain is constantly sort of
adapting to what's average
uh and there's a there's a really good
reason why that's true but it also
there's some really strong consequences
to that from from political
onwards
how do you describe what you do for work
how do i describe it
how long do you have oh wait we haven't
um what do i do for it so i'm sort of
like professionally a neuroscientist
okay so i study perception i study how
the brain makes meaning how it makes
meaning of itself how it makes me of the
world of other people so that's what i
in some sense i am
but we're kind of like lunatic fringe
neuroscience in the sense that um the
world becomes our lab
so what i do is we
mean not just me my lab what i call the
lab of misfits
and what we what we do is we basically
try to understand the principles by
which we we see the prince and hear and
touch the principles by which we make
perception and then we try to give
people insight into those principles
uh through immersive experiences and so
they can actually embody it
and then through that hopefully give
them understanding which then gives them
freedom to then do something about the
perception
so i mean you you do amazing things in
nightclub immersive experiences for us
that becomes a lab
right
the world is effectively the world isn't
a stage for us the world is a lab
literally you started a nightclub in one
of your labs
yeah yeah so we turned we've we actually
have turned the lab into a nightclub we
booked an underground victorian prison
in uh clarkenwell in east london is
absolutely brilliant space uh and we you
know sold out within minutes on time out
we had the people come
and you know they they they come they're
separated from whoever they came with
they're me met by this person in a b
outfit as in a caretaker be not like
dressed up as stripes um so the space is
filled with actors and everything and
and then the first thing they do there
they have to spit into a vial
uh because we're going to measure their
cortisol levels before and after and
everything in the space becomes measured
people know this is not an accident and
it's not done surreptitiously i mean
they know that they they're being
measured even from the way they dance
uh we have primatologists watching
people dance
the way that the food that they eat how
they eat whether they eat by candlelight
everything we had them going into prison
cells and then we had someone going into
a panic but they didn't know it was an
actor who was going into a panic and
then we're measuring to see how people
respond or like we're dependent on the
participant
yeah and then we're measuring
everybody's heart rate how they respond
but then also the personality profess
who steps forward to help who starts
panicking themselves who gets contaged
or you just stick 20 people into a dark
room and shut the door
and then just wait
it's amazing how long people will just
sit there and they eventually start like
now what and
they don't
often don't occur to them so well maybe
we should just leave and
so we're sort of measuring these types
of things
all that kind of stuff it's brilliant
it's wonderful how many people went in
this instance so some that one was uh 75
people so sometimes they're very
intimate and then times they can be
massive um but for us
these experiences um they're not just an
attempt for us to bet understand uh the
human mind
but for people to better get a better
understanding themselves
so our my personal deeper motivation
is to give people a sense of agency
and and humility and compassion and
creativity um but you don't have a
choice unless you know you have what and
choice begins with awareness
so we also give the data back to people
so they walk away with a deeper
understanding of themselves
and that's really what i'm after
we don't then say what to do with it
because that's up to them if you tell
people what to do you've actually taken
it from them
but you give them the agency of choice
but you give them the information from
which to make a decision
and how you do that reveal can actually
be really challenging because if you
tell someone something different from
what they think be true about themselves
that can actually be a real challenge
for them
they could actually completely resist it
in fact you can make them go in the
opposite direction
like a reverse self-fulfilling prophecy
well in a way so if i tell you something
about you or if you tell me something
right and and we're seeing this all over
the place right now i mean we've seen it
for years but we're seeing it very
strongly in politics especially in the
u.s
but if i tell you something about uh you
tell me something right and i show you
give you all kinds of data to show that
you're wrong
right
there's a very good chance you'll
actually hold stronger to your view than
you did before right
why well it depends to to the extent
that you've actually identified with the
thing to which i'm now contradicting
right uh well the data is contradicting
so you'll hold stronger because actually
to doubt that piece of information is
actually doubt who you are
and
that is possibly the strongest
um
system or strongest context for
uncertainty and we we as you know we'll
talk about we hate uncertainty and we
loathe it often not in all situations
but in almost every situation we hate
uncertainty
what were some of the best things that
you learned from your nightclub
experiment the most interesting things
well um
a couple has just come off the top of my
head first of all um
the uh
that people dance the premise people are
promiscuous and they're dancing
right but they dance in this in the same
way they have conversations
so you you dance with the same number of
people
as you do when you have conversations
but you switch your partners more often
so it's as if you're having a
conversation with someone through the
physical movement
which is kind of cool i think
um
another aspect is uh
this was a great experiment i thought um
i love designing experiments it's to me
it's like an art form i think it's a
beautiful thing uh and
so but this one actually had to be
designed because we're trying to get
around alcohol licensing
so we couldn't actually serve alcohol we
couldn't get an alcohol license
right you'll know all about this right
so we're going to get an alcohol license
but it turns out you can give alcohol
away for free
i didn't know this right
right the work around man if you've not
got a license to sell it just give it
away and put it into the ticket
um well in our case we said well how do
we turn this into an experiment so we
decided to turn into an experiment on
donation
so people could could donate publicly or
they could donate privately and if they
donated privately again we turn it into
a theatrical experience my the creative
director of my lab was previously
artistic director cirque du soleil and
you know so we can turn these things
into wonderful um experiences or she can
so um but in this case uh you went and
you crawl to this thing there's a punch
and judy thing and you you know so it
was all theatrical and it was very very
secret how much you donated right
and then you got a raffle ticket and
with that raffle ticket you could then
get a drink
um or you donated publicly
and if you donated publicly you went
into this wonderful massive photo booth
with a very well known portrait
photographer and you got your picture
taken with how much you donated and then
you got projected 10 foot by 10 foot
above the dance floor with how much you
donated right so it was really public
okay turns out men donate more publicly
than they do privately maybe not a
surprise women don't
they donate just as much
okay
then all those photographs of the men
got sent to a bank of
computers and women rated the physical
attractiveness of the men and in half
the pictures they could see the donation
the other half they don't so they
weren't asked to make any comment about
the donation but how attractive
physically attractive were these men
and what do you think who was more
attractive in terms of donation what do
you think man with more resources
so it turns out the more you donated the
less physically attractive you appeared
to be
interesting why do you think that it is
showing off
too much conspicuous consumption
or yeah and also just
one of the most attractive features of
another person is their authenticity
we're highly wired highly tuned to
detect someone's authenticity why
because to um
to be lied to
um to be tricked during evolution it was
a really bad idea right it really you
know to that's why um
and also the authenticity of a company
it's why in fact the lava mystics works
with brands to say it's not enough just
to have a purpose you know you can have
these wonderful purposes but unless
you're authentic in it it's just a
slogan
and people will detect that in
authenticity think of that pepsi
advertisement
a year or two ago you might be familiar
this was in america where
uh i forget the the um celebrity that
they had come and it was on black lives
matter is building basically very
opportunistic on the current uh cultural
climate at the time and they created
this sort of extravaganza
music video type thing
it completely backfired
and in fact it took them over a year to
get back to where they were simply
because they were detected to be
inauthentic but opportunistic
so when a guy is actually donating and
we're not talking lots of money you know
10 15 quid or something like that
the women are detecting this like
so what are you trying to compensate for
you're you're being inauthentic you're
trying to show off and it literally
manifests in being less physically
attractive
[ __ ]
so authenticity is
super important
um in in personal uh um one-to-one
relationships but also corporate
relationships all these guys trying to
get [ __ ] by doing philanthropy they've
got it the wrong way around be a
cheapskate well well not necessarily
right not necessarily because actually
if you think that five quid or something
like that it's not a huge cost
okay um to you now if on the other hand
you donated your time
or you donated all your money so it's
not just how much money is whether to
what extent is actually a real cost so
um
a sign of authenticity is that you're
spending effort on something for which
you're not going to gain
okay um and so or at least not directly
and so
you know i'm these guys were looking to
gain something but if they gave all
their money well that's a huge signal
that means you really care about
something you're really taking a hit
it's a bit like when i was growing up my
mom said you know gift isn't a gift
unless it costs you
right um if if i just found something
and say oh here you go chris you'd be
like that's that's great but was it
really a gift for me it's like didn't
cost me anything
and your brain detects that
yeah skin in the game is a measure of
authenticity you can't fake effort in
that way
in many in many sense yeah which is why
often in startups whatever they they
want to see
they want to see the you know the
founder has skin in the game the
different people have skins game or why
you actually would give equity to the to
the team so they all have skin in the
game and then reduce their in you know
salary so everyone is working for the
same cause you see this in startups that
are growing as well that the founder
often gets kept on so a buddy of mine
who i had on the show recently aubry
marcus his company on it just got
purchased by unilever for a incredibly
large undisclosed amount to take it
global but he's being kept on
why
because that's a very public show
of authenticity that if you just get
bought out by some huge big corporation
and then you rip the
figurehead out of the company it's a lot
harder to find that authenticity as
opposed to perhaps step by step slowly
pull aubrey's face away from the
branding and blah blah blah i don't know
what the plan is but that seems like a
plan yeah
so that that's part of it so i actually
have two startups myself and
and the um
historically what often happen is that
these big companies would buy up a
startup because they're buying they're
trying to bind the creativity and then
they break up the startup
what they don't realize is that the team
is the group of people and the culture
that actually
often enabled that success so you get a
lot of less vc investors but a lot of
angels and super angel investors they're
investing not in your idea there's a
there's a very
significant investor i know out of
israel he's he's got 80 different
investments he doesn't care what your
idea is he invests in you
right and so that's one aspect is that
these large companies are realizing that
it's actually that team that made it
successful if they break up that team
and they dissolve it and they they sort
of bring it you know diffuse it into the
company they've lost the actual um
beauty that was created in the first
place this is one of the reasons why you
could argue whatsapp instagram etc
they've remained teams within facebook
that's one point um the other aspect is
what i call the host effect
so
you put on dinner parties right
so the um when you go to dinner parties
or the night clubs right
the um
the personality of the f of the host
infects the party right if you're a
quiet host and you're like this i'm very
introverted the whole party is quiet but
if you're an extroverted host
and you're sort of celebratory the whole
party is extroverted and celebratory
right so the group takes on the
personality of the host
okay and as soon as the party becomes a
about the host you're no longer hosting
it's now all and it's now about you
okay so a brilliant host infects the
party with their own energy
for better or for worse well what's true
for the party is also true i believe for
a company
the personality to the founder the
personality of the of the people who run
the company but in particular the
founder will infect the whole company
so which is one of the reasons why you
see facebook the way it is it is in some
sense the manifestation of the
personality of its host
okay a classic a very good example i
know of a classic is between target and
walmart walmart in in the states
uh there are two companies that were
formed around the same time in the same
parts of the states in minneapolis
one of them was a the host the founder
was a nickel and dime
corner store as cheap as possible right
the other one was founded by a
department store where it was service
that mattered the customer mattered
right they both start in the same place
both of those
hosts are now dead
the companies live on target has one of
the highest loyalty
of any other store in america it's like
80 outrageous
right why it's because of that
personality of that host continued well
beyond
think about new york new york was not
founded by the british in the period the
puritans it was founded by the dutch it
was new amsterdam
and at that time hundreds of years ago
amsterdam was the place that people went
to for religious freedom
so if you as long as you
profess loyalty to amsterdam you could
practice whatever religion you wanted so
it was a real place of freedom which is
still kind of true for holland and
amsterdam in general
think of new york new york is not like
america it's not like anywhere new
york's new york i used to live there for
last five years right
and it still has that personality of its
founders of its host
so i think that's the other reason why
they keep on
the founders because they want to
maintain or they should at least
maintain that personality maintain that
um that host effect
what about all i know that you've spent
a lot of time looking at that oh um so
all's a wonderful thing i think all is
possibly one of our most powerful
perceptions uh so what is all um so
other people have defined r to be
that moment where we think a surprise
we can't understand it
but then to understand it means i
probably have to shift my current
understanding of myself in the world
so surprises surprise wonder is that's
amazing but i bet this fits with winrar
i already know so a magic show gives
wonder right i bet if i understood the
trick it would still make sense to me
right but
aw is something else it's like i that's
amazing i don't get it and i'm going to
have to shift my view so that's kind of
like a formal thinking about awe
but what does it do is really powerful
so we we did an experiment with cirque
du soleil
which is a wonderful group to of course
be working with
and
we measured people's brain activity and
we measured what changed in their
perception and behavior of themselves in
the world before and after their
experience of all because who better to
work with and circulate circus later
trait all right
and what we found
uh well actually we found a couple of
things what other people found which is
your pro-social behavior increases so
you want you look after other people
you're more likely to open a door for
someone else you're more likely to
listen etc
but also what happens is your tolerance
to risk increases you're more willing to
take risk and you're better able at
taking it
um
your need for what's called cognitive
closure your need for certainty
decreases you're more willing to sit
within uncertainty and even your whole
perception of yourself changes
so
when asked afterwards are you someone
who is more likely to experience all in
the past
you're more likely to say yes in other
words you start reframing yourself as
someone who experiences awe
your ego diminishes you feel small but
connected to all those around you
including nature
right and i would argue that in some
sense that's what people are often
referring to when they when they think
about being in the zone
um being in the moment
you're actually getting yourself out of
you
and in some sense this is what
psychedelics are all doing this is what
psilocybin or ayahuasca it's getting you
out of you
and i think in some sense that's her
most powerful perceptual state
ironically is not thinking of yourself
but in a world where everyone's far more
neurotic
spending too much time in their heads a
lot of time you know what we celebrate
is cerebral horsepower you know sort of
along with the scientific method and
rationality and utilitarianism and a
meritocracy comes
everyone thinking more iq points more
time inside of my head is the solution
to me getting more of the things that i
want in life you know love money status
whatever
and all of that might be true depending
on the context that you're in
so you're if you're in a society and a
culture where that's actually celebrated
yeah you will be more successful um will
the society itself be more successful in
long term possibly not right so
if you create a society which says
that's a good idea well then that is a
good idea at least for the short term it
works on the
[Music]
collaborative uh upholding right if
everybody considers it to be prestigious
to have these things then by its very
nature it's like a democratically
elected um set of status metrics but
what about so let's say that someone is
spending a little bit too much time
inside of their own heads they're being
too neurotic and and they really are
just too up here what are some of the
things i'm going to guess that trying to
find an experience of awe would be one
of them things to take them out of their
heads
that would be one um there are also
other examples that i would say um call
um being a sandbar
so
being a sandbar is to be there to enable
someone else to step into uncertainty
um so for instance there's
increasingly not you know the
meditation is a wonderful thing um yoga
is worth all these things are wonderful
things um but often they are taken out
of the context in which they actually in
some sense evolved
meditation
mindfulness for instance comes out of a
buddhist tradition okay and the buddhist
tradition comes out of a culture that
was actually very socially oriented
and one of the reasons is because it
comes from a certain physical
environment in which that arise um
monsoons etc so social is very important
and we've done experiments where
people who from the far east actually
look at images differently than people
from the west they're more like their
eyes more likely look at the background
whereas your eyes are more likely to
look at the foreground
okay the illusions that i make are
stronger for people on the east than
they are for people in the west because
they use context social context and
actually physical context more
um
so
what a recent study has shown that if
you practice mindfulness within a
context of being more socially and
oriented towards others it increases
your generosity
if however you practice mindfulness in a
context of individualism where your
focus is yourself
it actually decreases your generosity
so it would have at least in terms of
generosity it would have been better not
to be
mindful right it actually makes it worse
because what's happening is you become
more and more focused on self
and often with anxiety that is where
it's it's coming from it's that constant
focus on yourself where often and we all
experience that as soon as you get
yourself out and you start thinking of
someone else you start giving
suddenly things become a little bit
better
right
so in some sense there's a not a
solution but there is a strategy and i
apply it myself when i'm feeling pretty
rubbish i will purposely go out of my
way to sometimes you have to force
yourself to go and do something that's
useful to someone else
do something that's kind
and it's maybe sounds like a cliche
but it actually is shifting your your
attention away from yourself
because i can get you i mean um you know
you think about pain and chronic pain
and you know i could put a piece of sand
in your hand
and if i got you to focus on that piece
of sand as much as possible it would
become eventually very painful
so which means the whole of my skin the
sensation of my skin becomes focused on
this tiny little bit
right and that can that can be what
starts happening to people
and yet it's all in the guise and i
don't mean intentionally but it all
feels like it's in the guise of um in
service of
a larger
sense of self or larger world so there's
this alignment between what we say our
intentions and what we do
what about dread have you looked at the
other side of all
dread oh
i haven't but i like that idea um
what would you say is polar opposite
the opposite of all would be in some
sense what we were i think the opposite
of all in some sense is narcissism
right because
say i have a particular view of all
which is people think that it diminishes
your ego because you feel connected i
think in some sense it expands your ego
what i mean by that is now my ego if i
define my ego and you can define your
ego in in some more formal ways more
sort of cloaky ways but if i define my
ego very loosely in terms of to wit that
to which i identify
if i start identifying with nature
with the animals that around me or with
you then in some sense my ego has
expanded and it's expanded to include
things that aren't just within my own
skin
right so in some sense i think it's
expanded so the opposite of that is
contraction
where you're completely self-focused
completely focused on yourself
um
lack of generosity not wanting to take
risks completely fearful of uncertainty
that's where we get anxiety that's where
anxiety lives that's where depression
lives
which doesn't say they're the opposite
but in necessary in a formal sense but
in some sense in a behavioral sense and
perceptual sense they are you mentioned
about focus focusing on a grain of sand
specifically but focus and distraction
are just two of the most common desires
and ailments i think for people at the
moment smartphones and social media and
too much electronic devices have you
ever done any work on focus and
distraction and attention
we're we're actually in the middle of
the study of that just now we're
actually focused uh ironically or
coincidentally on um
on silence and the power of silence
um
and it's a fascinating topic it's a
fascinating topic um and i can't go into
necessarily all the findings that we
have so far but from what we already
know from other people don't have done
silence is one an understudied
phenomenon but it's also a deep human
need
but it's also something that people
thinking of your the word used before
dreaded
so there's a study for instance showing
that at least for um this group of
people they're studying in a young group
people would rather be physically harmed
than sit in a room
for about 16 minutes and do bugger all
right
so when they so they had to do that once
and when asked to do it a second time
they said you could do it second time or
you could shock yourself
they chose the shock
right
rather than sit and just and not
meditate just sort of sit and do nothing
right and yet we know you get increased
neurogenesis i.e brain cells start being
born
uh if you're in silence
um we know that your heart rate goes
down there's some estimates from the
european union that
literally millions of uh
years of well-being have been lost
across the european countries
um it's even more recently been
associated with the
potential for alzheimer's disease the
lack of silence
and of course it's very interesting what
is silence because there's no such thing
as silence
right and what's more your brain is
super active
when you're in the dark or when you're
in silence and in fact i went i did a
dark experience for four four days um uh
last month and that was the fascinating
thing we could talk about but
the uh
and
so to your you have cells that are
active when the lights go on but you
also have cells that are active when the
lights go off because your brain you
know darkness is not the lack of light
it's or lack of activity it's your brain
saying things are dark it's telling you
things are dark and then when things are
light it's another set of cells saying
things are like light right so things
are very dark it's just that different
parts of your brain are active
and we are under using those when you
were talking about silence
is it
have you defined it as complete silence
or have you looked at things that are
undiscernable noises so like white noise
or driving in a car without music or
podcasts on for instance
so the it's it's
it's a it's a comp it's a difficult
question to answer i can give you some
some
some aspects of insight into this so
they're the most and when it comes to
say urban spaces the most important
noise that seems to impact people
is not your neighbors
it's the um industrial noise it's
transportation it's airplanes it's cars
it's building works in terms of decibel
levels
those are the source those are the
noises that actually causing the most
challenging and yet the ones we spend
most time focused on are the neighbors
right and it's like why those they're
actually they're they're doing less for
you
lean out of your window and scream at
the people driving past in your car
that's what you should be doing yeah
well the irony is that there could be a
massive building site where jackhammers
going across the street but the person
is going to open up their curtains and
tell their neighbor to turn down their
music right um and yet decibel-wise and
continuous-wise it's actually across the
street maybe it's partly because it
gives you that sense of agency
that you're in control of something
um and how am i going to stop this
construction site right so that's one
source sniper rifle
well that's your idea
but oh so the that's uh um
so that's one source of noise but
actually it might be
far more important noises internal noise
what i mean by that is the jitter that's
in your head
uh and so that's one one point is that
that that noise that's constantly i
can't focus or that's possibly a more
powerful noise than the others so you
could imagine for instance
those remarkable meditators buddhist
monks whatever
i'm sure they could sit on the middle of
an airfield
and feel no sense of lack of distress
by the noise coming past whereas you or
i would
so what's interesting is that our
sensitivity to noise varies depending on
who you are
your state of mind
and the noise that's going on inside
your head but equally for silence and
what is silence
i think sinus has something to do with
unpredictability
um
lack of agency
someone just suddenly comes in and
interrupts you in your mid thought right
this type of stuff
and there's also an element of nature we
do we have evolved to be in nature
as well
which is quiet
it's but it isn't is it i mean it's i
mean it if you go camping and you know
up on the hill here in ibiza i mean
there's this but it's not a cricket it's
not a circadian i don't know what it is
but at four in the morning it's
basically saying my house my house my
house my house my house over and over
again and it's like on the one hand i'm
thinking this is beautiful it's nature
on the other hand i was like shut the
[ __ ] up
right and it's really annoying but it's
nature so you know
not nature isn't actually that quiet but
we find it peaceful
what's happening inside of our brains if
we are
used to a high level of
input
if we're used to a high level of
stimulation yeah we adapt to it
you adapt to it so it's what i what
we're referred to in the very beginning
is redefining normality your brain is
constantly redefining normality so um
you go into
uh you go into a cinema everyone will
know this experience you're going to
once upon a time actually i don't in
britain can we go into the cinemas yet
yeah i can't remember okay um so you go
into the cinema and initially you know
the sun the the the lights are off
you know you can't see the steps you
can't see anything and you look like
[ __ ] and you sort of pause there and
you're waiting for it and what are you
waiting for you're waiting for your
brain to redefine normality in other
words to set itself to the average level
of illumination
and then if it's a matinee for instance
and you walk out and now in your
brightness it's like well that was
overwhelming and then again your brain
is resetting why because we can only be
sensitive to a small range your brain
cannot be equally sensitive to the
massive range
illumination in terms of intensity
varies a billion to one
we can't be sensitive to that whole
range simultaneously equally
so we have to pick our windows and we're
constantly adapting why because we want
to what we really want to detect is
change
so if i reset myself then i can detect
change around that around that average
okay so if you have lots of noise lots
of things going on
you will set reset yourself and that
will become an expectation
which means that if you you need to keep
that level of noise in order for it to
be normal
but this is also true
in terms if you think about not just say
the physiology of brightness but also
the physiology of ideas
one of the you could argue one of the
most
challenging consequences of what's
happening say in the states and not to
go political but in terms of say
neuroscience in terms of adapting
normality
is that
your brain will reset itself it will say
ah this is normal
what was previously not normal was
previously like i can't believe this is
happening we'll eventually say oh yeah
this is normal
and so the whole of society will shift
to that new normal and then we'll have
fluctuations around that now if that
shift is in a negative direction it will
then become normal and it will no longer
be seen as negative
right and then it will take another
shift down and another shift down right
because to not adapt requires energy
so my point to people often is decide
beforehand if you want to adapt to this
thing whatever that thing is
a relationship
a
level of light a level of sound a
political system whatever it is decide
beforehand if you want to adapt to it
because you will
because to not do it is hard
and that's you could argue what a
protest is a protest is the energy
required to not adapt
right but you also see this in complex
systems it literally requires energy
to not
change to the common average
think of people who are eccentric who
rebel it's very costly emotionally
socially but also physically
to not adapt
in some sense
i saw a study about people who usually
live in the city and then move out to
the country and people who live in the
country and move to the city and both of
them said that it was pretty unbearable
in terms of the amount of noise you
think well yeah but surely one of them
has to be better
than the other one you know there's got
to be a more optimal and it's like no no
the issue is this sort of overton window
of of um normal experience and then
somebody's been picked up and moved
outside of that and
change change requires energy adapt
yeah and and we find that really
challenging because we love familiarity
why do we love familiar because it's
predictable
and even when that familiarity is awful
we will often go for the familiar it's
awful than the unfamiliarity that we
don't know you know the old adage the
devil you know is better than the devil
you don't
right um in fact that is not necessarily
literally true
but we find that even to the extent that
when someone is has a physical ailment
so lots of studies have looked into this
we haven't but lots of studies show
looked into this you have a physical
element you don't know the cause of this
element
it's massively uncertain what this
causes what the cause is you finally get
and it's
you know you're feeling awful you're
mentally feeling awful all this kind of
stuff then you're given the diagnosis
that diagnosis
is a terrible diagnosis
there's this element of relief
it's like oh well at least i now know
even though what i now know is an awful
thing
that's how much we want and need that
sense of knowing that sense of
uncertainty
what did you do i mean uncertainty is
like your specialist subject what did
you look out to do with this
everything everything we look at isn't
is about uncertainty
in fact even my studio when we design we
only have a design along a single axis
this is the axis of uncertainty
sometimes we want to increase it
sometimes we want to decrease it
almost every one of our behaviors almost
every one of your behaviors is an
attempt to decrease uncertainty except
in one context
okay so i would argue that you know in
some sense that's why uber's successful
uber's successful not because they tell
you when a you know they enable you to
get a taxi easier faster you know that
that's true
but it's because they tell you when the
taxi is going to arrive
right
and to the extent that they get they get
that wrong people will stop using uber
and this has actually started happening
in some south american countries where
you know you over you order your uber it
says eight minutes five minutes four
minutes canceled 12 minutes
and people oh [ __ ] it and then they just
order a taxi or wait for a taxi right
but if i say
you know it's you know it's five minutes
i'm going to show you where it is even
your cortisol levels stay low right
you're no longer stressed because you
have certainty it's why in britain we
people they put the um time the bus is
going to arrive up on the bus schedule
even though it says 45 minutes
right it's like ah that's a payment but
at least i know
right um
so
everything that we almost everything we
do is an attempt to decrease uncertainty
and then we apply that in business and
in all kinds of aspects of our lives and
and we can actually even use that to
people use it to manipulate as well
um
so both in a positive and negative sense
so in the positive sense it's why
cliffhangers work
it's why game of thrones works because
what they're doing is they're they're
building up uncertainty and at the end
of every episode they finish on a minor
chord
and it's like ah i mean you know what
it's like right well i work with djs
here in ibiza and you know they call it
dropping the beat you know this better
and i right
what's the power of dropping the beat
well what they've done is they've built
up uncertainty they've built up
expectation not taxation your dopamine
levels are going up and all this kind of
stuff and what's the brain's greatest
need it's for that closure
it's for that uncertainty to be resolved
and then they drop the beat and your
whole body starts moving have you seen
it the whole rhythm of the whole room
everyone goes crazy but then sometimes
the dj's will play with you right and
they'll drop it to a minor chord
and be like oh no and then they ramp it
back up and they drop it right and
they're waiting they're waiting and then
they finally drop it right game of
thrones the same what they're brilliant
at is knowing which minor chord to
finish it at so you have to get that
closure
but personal relationships will also do
that
so if i create a sense of uncertainty in
you
and i'm the only source of resolving
that uncertainty
i now have a power dynamic over you
because i'm the only one who can give
you closure
so you'll find that often people will
even purposely create this you see this
in corporates they'll say i don't know
if you're gonna buy you know
you have a job for now i don't know
about next week you know they're they're
constantly creeping that uncertainty
and they're the ones that now have a
power dynamic over you but think about
the worst message to receive from your
partner we need to talk
yeah
dot dot
like if we need to talk then [ __ ]
ring me don't tell me that we need to
talk i'm just going to wallow in this
anxiety for the next hour
if you've got those messages a lot then
i'm
an ascended being now that's not
happened anymore
well no i we all get them right we all
get them and and it's possible in fact
that we've all delivered them too
right
um because
we in some sense we all kind of do this
the question is
um and because in some sense it's
natural
right but this is why what the lab is
trying to do is give people awareness
and we call it perceptual intelligence
once you're perceptually intelligent
when you once you have an understanding
of how and why you see what you do
now you actually have agency over that
because otherwise you're just behaving
reflexively and then you're telling
yourself post hoc rationale for why you
did it
and usually that post hoc rationale puts
you as a hero or puts the responsibility
onto someone else right but now as soon
as you realize okay everything i'm doing
is is grounded in in my assumptions my
bias et cetera many of which i've
created which i've inherited now you
actually have a choice
the natural response is to do x that's
fine
but now i actually have a choice to not
do x
right
um so
that's that's the power of of knowing
because otherwise you're also going to
create this power dynamic on people
right uh and you're not going to know
that you're doing it
there's a question
no no there's a quote that i love from
one of the buddhist masters and he says
the choice in life is between becoming
the pain of becoming aware of our mental
afflictions and the pain of being ruled
by them
that's the choice yeah that's choice
yeah that's right now that awareness is
only a first step actually there's
something that comes before awareness uh
which often people don't talk about
which is the desire to have awareness
right so we have an education program
we're creating a school in budapest with
um
some wonderful founders and and it's a
primary school that's turning into high
school and the first thing we focus on
is care
i want the kids to care
um because if they don't care in some
sense i don't care what they care about
i mean i do as a personal one right but
what i really want them to just care
because they don't care they're not
going to ask a question they're not
going to be willing to doubt
right etc so as soon as you have value
now i have the desire to have awareness
because awareness can be a bit of a pain
because you might become aware of things
that you didn't want to have awareness
of
you might become aware that you're a bit
of an idiot or you're a bit of an
[ __ ] right
that can be hard and we all have those
elements in us
the question is do you have the desire
to look
now once you've looked
the next step is do you have the desire
to act upon it
right because
that's where you can get to stress
coming back to um
uh something we were talking about
earlier the alignment between my
intentions
um and my words my intentions my actions
when they're out of alignment
we feel distress
but when they're in alignment we can
feel that sense of solidity whether or
not my intentions and actions are good
or bad is almost irrelevant is that
there there's an alignment that matters
that's more certainty right it's the
only difference is that this uncertainty
we're culpable for it
we've created look this is the narrative
that i'm telling myself or the world
about i will not cheat on my boyfriend
i'm i'm a loyal girlfriend and i'm gonna
do this and then you cheat on the
boyfriend
and the girlfriend goes well hang on a
second i i said this this is the
narrative that i told myself there's now
uncertainty because it's
not in line with my actions
that's right
um but then the fact is that almost
everything is contextual
as we've been kind of talking about
context is everything when it comes to
the brain hence the reason why it has to
redefine normality it's constantly
changing its perceptions and behaviors
according to context because it's
possible for her what happened is that
the context changed
right now the context could be an
internal context she herself changed it
as a person right or the circumstances
changed
um or she just wasn't didn't have the
awareness of who and why she did what
she did or or he right
now she has awareness because that's the
beauty of action
behavior there's truth and behavior
right so often i'll create a situation
and i've done this in my personal life
right it's like i'm gonna do this i'm
going to create a context now how you
respond to it will then tell me what's
true because words are easy
we all know what we're supposed to say
right in some sense
but now and you can say all these
wonderful things but the question is
what are you going to do now
and what you do whatever you do it's not
good or bad but what i'll what i'll have
is truth i'll now know
what's true
if you want to step towards well that's
true if you step away that's also true
but you can't
speak to stepping forward while at the
same time stepping away
right the stepping away is what's true
people make mistakes though or they
misjudge all the time with their actions
all the time does that still make it
true
ah um
what i mean by that is what's true in
that moment for them as far as what
their truth is
right now a mistake is
i mean mistakes are wonderful things
in my view conflict for me is a
beautiful thing to be in conflict it's a
wonderful thing
right to be in a situation is different
from you expect that's a wonderful thing
because we can only literally learn
through mistakes and through conflict
we never you can never expand from a
position of knowing you can only ever
expand from a position of not knowing
right this is why i have on my wrist i
have a tattoo that says i don't know
right
to celebrate i don't know
right that's a beautiful thing
the problem is that we so often engage
in a situation where we think we're
supposed to know
we're knowing in intelligence is
is where the cash is
but i would argue that actually it's in
not knowing where the cash is it's in
the beautiful question
is where the cash is
but to ask a beautiful question means
you have to engage in a situation with
humility that says i don't know in the
first place
i mean think going back to the dinner
party example
you know everyone's around the table
people are giving lovely insights did
you know x and people that's interesting
oh that's interesting
what happens when someone's a brilliant
question
the whole table stops
and they almost all say the same thing
ah i never thought of it that way
and yet the question didn't give any
insight didn't give any answer
suddenly it revealed to people an
assumption that none of them knew they
had in the first place
and people love that
why don't we love it when you and i are
in conflict or in two political parties
in conflict because we don't want to
move
because to move is to
is to step into uncertainty
and yet the only way to learn is to move
life is movement if you don't move you
die
it sounds like an equivalent between
optimism and pessimism here that you're
talking about
we often tell ourselves we rationalize
that we were either the victim or the
unintended
criminal perpetrator in a situation a
lot of the time if we do something that
is good it's because we hold ourselves
up high and if we do something that is
bad it's because the world forced it
upon us somehow is there an inverse of
that
because i have a bunch of buddies who
seem to self-berate
or they attribute their successes to
fluke
and they attribute their downfalls to
themselves
yeah
so there is a space that's in between
those two
so the first one you're describing is
ironically the measures that we use for
off that
that seligman and others have devised
for the measurement of optimism
so optimism as measured i would just
argue against this but optimism as
measured is when something good happens
you think it's going to last forever
it's going to affect the whole of my
life and it's largely because of me
when something bad happens it's going to
be very specific it's not going to
affect the rest of my life and it's kind
of your fault anyway
right
that's an optimistic person and we know
if you're optimistic that you're light
you live longer you're happier and all
that kind of said well who wouldn't be
because all the good things are for me
and all the bad things are because of
you
right whereas the more source stoic the
more the more sort of realist is like
actually this good thing that happened
is kind of not just because of me it's
also because of you
this bad thing that happened is not just
because it's also because of
circumstance so the concept of the demon
was actually and which then became a
familiar and was actually the basis of
the muse so the demons were like this
thing on your shoulder that sort of in
some sense took some responsibility for
the bad things that happened but they
also took responsibilities for the good
things that happened so it kind of
diminished your ego
it kept you humble
so that engaging the world with that
humility
and openness to the possibility that you
had some agency in whether it went wrong
or whether it went well
is actually i would argue that one of
the distinction between wisdom and
intelligence
wisdom to me is far more interesting
than say intelligence
dig into that film what do you mean
well first of all wisdom for in my view
you can't get it from a book it comes
from experience it comes from um
it comes from realizing that the world
is contextual this is what i would again
equate to say perceptual intelligence it
has humility it has compassion in it um
it engages with in conflict the desire
not to win
but with the desire to understand
and we can come to the distinction
between understanding and conflict like
whereas intelligence is different it can
be we often teach intelligence in school
we don't teach wisdom in the school
we're trying to create it we're looking
to teach wisdom i seeking understanding
rather than seeking knowledge rather
than seeking knowing
x and x happened on this date it's why
did that happen what was the
significance of that what was the
context in which that can then
generalize
right
so
that to me is
loosely a distinction between them
but when we enter not knowing with
either a desire to stand still
or even worse with the desire to
validate
so if you are in conflict often what we
do is we're seeking validation i want
you to agree with me
or you want me to agree with you
and so i need to validate you but what
you really want is to be understood
right
and so often when we when people are
dealing with conflict management
they often psychologists will say what
you want to do is find common ground oh
you like football oh i like football
that's great now
i know that actually what i'm trying to
do is convince you on something else so
i'm trying to get you to oh what kind of
buddies oh you both like arsenal well
you probably like newcastle i just like
newcastle but anyway so we're trying to
find that common ground and then it's
like now
let's talk about politics or something
well actually this is called
manipulation
but if i went to you and said you know
what chris i disagree with everything
you're saying
but i truly want to understand why you
feel this way because i truly think that
i might learn something but what i
really want is to understand you because
everybody makes sense to themselves just
not to other people there's an internal
law of physics inside you
that is the basis of your rational
decision
it's just that your physics are
different from mine your data is
different from mine
and so often i come to the point like oh
my goodness if i had that data
i would have that view too well
everyone's convinced of their own view
right like nobody nobody's fighting the
corner of a view that they don't believe
in for the most part there are some
people that are misaligned or sort of
willfully ignorant but even the people
that are willfully ignorant like they're
ignorant if they were convinced of
something if i convince you if i manage
to convince you that two plus two equals
five you are now convinced of that until
somebody convinces you a different way
are you familiar with chris voss's work
the fbi's ex-head negotiator for
kidnapping
oh no i i know of it but no not in
detail talk so his his book never split
the difference is you would i i would
recommend it super accessible read
you'll you'll chew through it and he
does a lot of the things
that you're talking about here so one of
the key tactics he has is called a
that's right
so you
still man the other side's position as
obsessively as possible
painful
second by second the most detail that
you can get every single thing
and what you're aiming for so this is
what i think is happening and you are
this way because of this and this is
your view and this is your view and this
is your view yeah
that's right that's what he wants that's
the response that he wants he tells this
story about a guy um that was a
kidnapper that was holding a bunch of
people in vietnam hostage
and this had been going on for months
months and months and months and they
just they couldn't make headway
and the guy that chris was there
coaching the actual uh negotiator
himself
chris said look we need to get that's
right out to this guy because we're not
getting anywhere and we're worried that
he's gonna kill the people that he's
with
so he says we need to get that's right
today so this guy takes
two hours
of explaining i understand that you
believe that vietnam was taken over by
imperialist powers i i appreciate why
this is coming from this is why you
think this this is why you think two
hours
that's right
the next day all of the hostages were
freed this guy
it completely done and another one the
other one that he does um that i thought
was interesting is
a lot of the time when people notice an
issue with the other side they'll say
what's wrong
two words
so much assumption so much assumption in
the sentence what's wrong his suggestion
and he i can't remember all of them it
ascends so you can ascend the
intensity but
one of the first ones is
it feels like there's something on your
mind
seems like there's something seems like
there's something on your mind
and then another sorry another final one
is when somebody wants to suggest
something to you in a deal and you can't
make it work
just cannot do it
his first response is
how am i going to do that
how am i going to make that work
and what you're seeing with a lot of
these is it it's
trying to find that bridge
how am i going to do that it opens it up
to the other side it seems like there's
something on your mind it invites
somebody in it's not judging what's
wrong it's like just such a disgusting
thing to say i mean we've all done it in
relationships the person's quiet and go
what's wrong you shout it at them and
you're like oh yeah because that's gonna
that's really going to encourage the
other person to tell you what's wrong
yeah and then that's right steal them on
the other side make them feel understood
genuinely and validated
well so i i would make a distinction i
absolutely agree with all of this um i
would make a distinction between the
understanding the validation because i
don't think it's you need to validate i
don't think i need to say you're right
what i think i need to say is i
understand ah
that actually makes sense given what you
think given the data given the
information that you're using
given your aims that makes i in fact i
would probably do that too
but now let's talk about your
assumptions
that underpin that right so i don't need
to validate you
and i don't need to be validated but
people want to feel like they're
understood
okay so um so i make a distinction
between those because if you can only
talk to people you can validate well
there are very few people you can talk
to it's only people whose positions you
agree with yeah that's right but if i'm
seeking understanding i can talk to
anyone
right um and also in doing so often you
learn but what's also really important
is often
i'm not saying he does this at all but
that people give rules or steps
to these processes
my argument is that these steps aren't
enough
they are very important they're very
insightful
but the most fundamental step is to want
to
because if you don't want to the steps
are irrelevant
when i talk to the businesses about
innovation and leadership and things
like this they know what are the five
ways to be you know five what are the
five ways to become a good leader it's
like okay well lead by example admit
mistakes and all this kind of stuff
right but my argument is that you can't
apply a formula
right what you have to it's a way of
being in the world
because if you don't have this way of
being and it's not a way of being that
you switch on when you walk into your
office
right this is a way of being in which
you engage with everybody
and it's that way of being that says i
want to understand i want to expand my
perception
but to expand my perception requires not
knowing
inquires it requires embracing
uncertainty requires realizing
uncertainty is an essential step it's
the ramping up of the music
right the closure the dropping of the
beat is irrelevant if you haven't ramped
up the music first and orgasm is
irrelevant if you haven't had the build
up first i mean literally an orgasm is
the dropping of the beat right
but it's a cycle it's a spiral you have
to go out and then you come back you go
out and you come back
but you have to have the desire to move
in the first place otherwise no matter
what strategy or formula you give me i'm
not going to engage in it
which is why that's what i focus on is
that desire
can you cultivate that desire what we're
talking about here is that a lot of the
time people want the five-minute booty
blaster shortcut to
getting whatever being a good leader
having company culture getting more
performance out of my staff and that
needs to it's much more
embodied and
scalable if you have someone that
genuinely wants that now presumably
there's absolutely still a place for the
tactics because somebody that has desire
but no tactics is just spraying into the
dark with their with their bullets
absolutely as opposed to yeah so you
need direction and speed
but yep how can people develop the
desire or do you have a do you have ways
for for people to do that
uh we do um and
uh so when i do the corporate talks and
everything i speak to them personally
first of all about uh how what we're
doing here could actually be relevant to
the whole of your life but also you
speak to what people's fundamental
desires are which is to have a
meaningful life to be happy etc and in
the case of business to be successful
so you say actually and you have to show
that this is actually a more successful
way of being in the world
it might be a harder way it might
require you become having awarenesses
that you maybe don't want uh etc etc but
actually you show how it's in some sense
self-serving and i don't mean that in a
negative sense i think in some sense
every behavior is in some sense selfish
right every behavior is in some sense
trying to increase my perceived value of
myself
the question is how do i increase my
perceived value is it by screwing as
many people as possible is by having a
maximum bank account is it by
adding a smile to as many the faces of
as many people as possible where do i
get that value
is fundamental
but the consequence is all the same i
get a stronger sense of value of myself
right so but similarly actually with the
monetary value of a company to show that
actually to be authentic in your purpose
will make you a company that has higher
loyalty both internally and externally
that will affect your bottom line
because you'll become a more resilient
company when things go up and down
so you you show how actually this is not
just philanthropy this is not just a
nice way of being
it actually has real impact on your life
but it's also a harder road
but then the things that we put more
effort into we tend to perceive those
things to have higher value as well it's
called the ikea effect
right
so that's i remember general the
strategy i spoke to rory sutherland
about this and he is great he's [ __ ] me
what a guy he's just a force of nature
and we were talking about the fact that
um
pick your own strawberries is very
different to
cheap strawberries because cheap
strawberries sound cheap but these
strawberries are so cheap because you
have to go pick them yourself there's
justification in that and it's the ikea
effect all over
yeah that's right um absolutely i mean
um
the uh
and and then of course there's a sense
of ownership et cetera all kinds of
wonderful things which is why often when
we create our physical environments and
these immersive experiences what we're
also trying to do is have people come to
their own insights
because often as soon as you tell
something to someone you've actually
taken away from them
so what we want is we we call it
creating parallel so we create com
parallels in the experience
and enable people to find the
connections between the parallels and
that's then now they own it
now if you then find connections between
parallels that we didn't anticipate well
that's a discovery that's science
so we also then have within our
experience making true
discoveries that no one's known not just
you or i didn't know um
but and then you and then you suddenly
have ownership of that and you behave
very differently towards it talk to me
about leadership you have an interesting
framework for how people can be better
leaders or the fundamental
elements of leadership
yeah so leaders um
leaders effectively as we were talking
about before in terms of the host effect
first of all you know they determine the
um
the not just the culture as such but the
almost a
hard to measure
aspects of a company that sort of enable
people for instance to to be uncertain
to ask questions
so often leaders are thought they're
supposed to have the answers
and this is where we're going where in
fact the best leaders lead others into
uncertainty as opposed to create
uncertainty or think that they
themselves have to solve the uncertainty
what they do is create an environment in
which others can actually ask questions
and then we can prosecute those
questions so i'd argue for instance in
terms of science or laboratory
science is not about iterating to better
questions it's about iterating sorry
iterating to better answers it's
actually iterating to better and better
questions
but you need an environment
in which you can actually have that
iteration process where
not knowing asking questions is
celebrated
we also know for instance that
there are three qualities of a leader
that are associated with excessive any
one company it's lead by example admit
mistakes and see qualities in others
so
lead by example is a space that creates
trust
now you can't
engage in uncertainty outside of space
that is trusting
so let's leave my admit mistakes as a
space that says hey not knowing is good
here
and c qualities in others is a space
that celebrates diversity
but what's interesting there's a lot of
talk about diversity diversity by itself
is not necessarily a good or bad thing
what often people forget is you also
have to integrate across that diversity
it's not just about having a lot of
different stuff
so
this is actually comes down to physics
so um in some sense science what your
brain is constantly looking for
understanding
is finding a principle
that transcends context
so when you understand something you
actually understand it at a deeper level
where now you can apply that
understanding to multiple environments
okay and that's because you've been able
to integrate across the diversity of
those environments you've been able to
find something common
right um so
whether it be
talking to a woman or a man or whatever
it might be right and then of course
you're trying to find more specific to
that person for instance but what you're
trying to do is find um the thing that
integrates across diversity so e equals
mc squared it doesn't care if it's a
planet or a bowling ball or a chicken
right it's just
it's gravity right it doesn't care it
doesn't depend on all that so you're
trying to find those principles and
that's because you're integrating across
diversity
so in terms of a company you're trying
to not just have diversity you're trying
to find um how how these different
people of different kinds of backgrounds
whatever can integrate can communicate
can share
it makes me think
it makes me think a lot about the
about the way that
that leadership works about the way that
companies that are very effective
the asking questions thing
and the
what was the first like competence what
was the first one how did you frame that
one
so lead by example by example yeah so
yeah i had will saw on the show recently
talking about the status game and in
that he said that there's three primary
routes this technically two but three
kind of three primary routes to status
uh and one of them is fear basically
kind of force
another one is
trustworthiness
and the final one is sort of usefulness
or competence or virtue something along
those lines and these are the three
fundamental ways in which people find
status the reason for this is
makes a lot of sense like those would be
three ways that somebody could become
renowned powerful admired whatever you
want to call it within a tribe and it
makes me think about the person at the
top of the tree
that there is a
there's a requisite amount of competence
that's needed so for instance we use in
our um events company we have quite a
vertically um sort of stratified company
in terms of managers we have junior
managers and event managers and then
senior event managers and city managers
and then we have directors it's not a
tremendously big company but we draw
these guys out so that it gives them
this sense of progression and it also
allows us to sort out pay packages
efficiently and the guys that have
the most respect from the team below
them
often have a number of different
elements together but one of the ones
that they almost always do is that they
have the biggest guest list totals so if
these guys are regularly putting in the
hard yards this is the fundamental thing
that everybody does it's the sales right
it's let's say that the director of the
sales company still does sales and you
can see him on a board
and yeah maybe he's got more experience
than everybody else and yeah maybe his
contacts are better than everybody else
but he's still got to put the sales on
the board right and his board's the same
as your board and he makes you know
that's that's the way it works
a lot of the guys that have been our
most successful managers throughout time
have been the ones that have displayed
competence that are seen by everybody
else everybody else gets to see it's on
the same score sheet that they're on and
they can compare their performance with
those you'll see this in crossfit as
well this is one of the reasons i think
that the crossfit open has had so much
uptake it's the first fitness
competition ever where the world
champion you get to compete against him
you do the same workout with the same
weights the same movement specs and you
get to go oh my god he did it in 9
minutes and 40 seconds i did it in 20
minutes like how how stupid am i like
i'm so blah blah blah you get to you're
right because we can see competence very
very
clearly displayed in front of us and i
think um
as a small business owner it's one of
the interesting things thinking about as
you rise up through the
through the ranks
i'm a big proponent of people earning
their bread and butter and really
understanding each of the different
levels of their business maybe when you
get to the stage where you've got like
board members that are kind of more like
advisory or specialized perhaps this
becomes because you're less of a
figurehead you're not actually
interacting with the people
um
but for instance with podcasting a lot
of
guys that start podcasting if they want
to build a big channel they'll try and
get an editor on board quickly or a
video guy
and you're like well hang on if they
come to you if you're unhappy with
something to do with the audio and you
don't know what you're talking about if
you say it's a bit this and you're just
using vague language that person's not
going to have as much respect for you if
you're able to actually really use the
correct terminology and the same thing
goes for houses so if you have a
property portfolio my advice is you
should manage your properties for
perhaps a year or a couple of years and
then you can get a letting agency in why
well because if you need to sit down
with somebody in a meeting and have a
conversation about why your properties
are being mismanaged and you don't
understand the processes even at least
on sort of a you know a broad level you
have no idea what you're talking about
it's going to be much more difficult to
command respect so yeah competence
appears to be
a pretty impressive drug
very much so as i i'd also think about
confidence in terms of reliability as
well which is hugely important when when
people are reliable whether it be at a
personal relationship level or in a
corporate um company level um that
reliability and confidence you're right
creates a sense of trust
um
with that said
and also there's because there's a sense
of earning it but it also enables you i
would argue that the best
leaders enable others to become
competent
okay
but in order to do so that's where i
think a leader becomes a mentor and more
sort of the traditional sense instead of
telling them what to do you create an
environment for them to become competent
and actually it will make the
organization more successful
rather than each individual competing
over competence they're actually in some
sense competing over the ability to
enable others to become competent but in
order to become competent you have to
understand the space in which the person
is engaging
right now there's also a flip side to
that though because the leader can also
the person who's very competent can also
become an expert
and experts are really they're very
efficient
but they're really bad at asking a good
question
why is that
because they know what they're not
supposed to ask
so over and over again the experts will
say no we don't do it that way no that
can't be done no it hasn't been etcetera
etcetera there'll be no no this is the
way you do constricting for the people
that are below them because they don't
get to learn by failing
yes that's one and two that the um the
expert is focused on efficiency
which is why i'm a huge celebrator of
being naive not ignorant but naivete
because people who are naive can ask
brilliant questions but they don't know
they're great questions
so it's not that they're thinking
outside the box they're just in a
different box
okay the experts in this box and this is
the way we do it in this box and we're
gonna be very efficient and that's a
great idea if the world didn't change
right but then the world changes and
what what the leader has to do is change
with it which means they have to
actually balance creativity with
efficiency
that means balancing naive with experts
so in my own team in my own our own um
work we try to have a diversity but that
diversity in this well we have lots of
different kinds of diversity but in this
instance is diversity between naive and
expert
because a brilliant expert can can't ask
great question but they can recognize a
great question when asked
right because they're open it's like ah
[ __ ] i thought we should have done it
this way
this whole last 20 years we've been
doing it this way but now that you
mention this
i've never thought of it that way but
let's go in that direction
now i'm enabling you to be competent
right um and that's where the
self-awareness comes in that i have
knowing that you have biases you have
assumptions that come from a history and
often a history that you inherited
um so it's being also willing to step
away from that
as well which is i would argue a very
strong sense of being competent because
confidence is also about having courage
and when
you know as my mom used to say a black
belt doesn't have to say he's he or she
is a black belt they just are
so when you have that sense that of
competence it means you're no longer
trying to prove yourself you're never
trying to prove your competence you just
are
you just live it and you enable others
to live it
right um and part of that is to to
understand that sometimes you get it
wrong
and not that you got it wrong but being
able to expand your own sense and that's
how you get resilience that's how you
get agility
in in an individual or in a company
and think about personal relationships
if that personal relationship isn't
moving
if a romantic relationship isn't i would
argue expanding then in some sense it's
dying
but so often the people want to stay
still and initially that's okay
but after a year or two or three years
you're still standing still it's like ah
you know
and then eventually one wants to move i
don't mean move on but they want to
expand and the other is like oh no but
that's scary because i kind of like it
the way it is
because that's that's kind of i don't
know what that's like over there
but now things that don't move things
that don't expand literally just die
what new experiments have you got coming
up anything fun that you can tell us
about
so we're doing a set of experiments on
uh we're hopefully starting a set of
experiments on touch the power of touch
which i think is a fascinating topic
and
we're also just finishing a set of
experiments on the power of home
all right
yeah um and and i can't go into the
details of it um uh but we're finding
some
powerful wonderful um insight into the
importance of home for your brain
and how we feel about home
and so
so touch and home and silence we're
currently working on and then
we're
hopefully going to be working with a
wonderful person called perry who who
also runs a very like yourself an
important podcast etc and he works on
chronic pain
so we're going to be doing some
experiments on chronic pain and then
we're also working with another group of
war veterans with ptsd
and and trying to better understand how
we can facilitate and help them
uh
and measure this the impact of certain
treatments on ptsd including uh
ayahuasca
why are you innovator
i said i
it's kind of a short question a long uh
short answer and long answer um why am i
because um i found myself here
um and now creating a life here in some
sense but about a year and a half ago so
the longer but i'll try to keep brief
answer is that about a year and a half
ago um i packed up my living in
manhattan so i've been in britain for 25
years and then i moved to
new york
and then
as the sec as a second lockdown was
about to start i packed up my house in
manhattan put everything in storage
rented a rag top and what i called turn
left
and i drove across america
my mom was just diagnosed with
parkinson's so i went to stay with her
then i cycled down the west coast
uh of the states and then i drove back
across and basically for the last year
and a half two years i've been living
out of one bag
and why it's in some sense because well
i study uncertainty and
and i believe in being a trope i believe
you should be the thing that you talk
about or at least try as much as
possible
and and also it's research for a new
book i'm writing so i've just been
movement and now i found myself here and
so now
um that we're doing some wonderful
things we just created a new space here
and and we'll run experiments and events
and things like that here
uh and
uh and so that's why i find myself in
ibiza is that for the foreseeable now
uh for the foreseeable but i travel
probably like yourself i travel a great
deal and so it's a wonderful place to
then come back to you
because we i was in ibiza and we were
going to do this in person but then i
looked at where you are on the map and
i've been to some pretty wavy afters
i've been to some naughty after parties
in ibiza but i've never been as far
north as you are you are
off the top of the yeah
but for quite a
far north is like 40 minutes away it's a
small island yeah yeah yeah whatever
whatever no but isn't it funny how
relative that is like
it's all the way on the other side it's
so true yeah um and it's the north and
the north of that is very different from
the southland i'm new here so but um
there's a very different feel
and it's beautiful and all that so yes
i'm in the north
uh but it would have been fun to do it
uh together but um next time man next
time if you still don't know if you saw
that next year then we can do it look
bolado ladies and gentlemen people want
to keep up to date with what you're
doing where should they go
well um they should go to lavamisfit.com
uh lavamisfist.com and they can actually
find we like my traveling and the i
don't know stuff and all that well i i
post something every two weeks on uh a
blog we also run experiments on people
so they can take part of experiments and
better understand themselves
uh we also have a lab misfits instagram
page and i just started my first
personal instagram
um so i'm doing a 48 descending
descending into the muck and the mire
along with the rest of us get down here
so maybe right because i'm going to turn
it into an experiment
but it's a social experiment it's a
personal experiment um because i've been
resistant so i want to see what happens
i'm doing an experiment on myself so
people are welcome to come along on that
experiment what's the what's your
instagram
uh it's bolado and the other one is lab
misfits
yeah until next year dude
all right brilliant to talk to you catch
you later on thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace